[Music]
one of the states being hit especially
hard by the pandemic is
arizona it now has the worst covid
infection rate
in the country yesterday arizona
reported more than
5 600 new cases and nearly 200 more
deaths
it's now considering taking
extraordinary action to cope with the
crisis
carter evans is at a hospital in phoenix
carter good morning
good morning this hospital behind me
like many across the state
is inundated with covet patients the
situation is so precarious that hospital
officials are now warning about
something
we've heard in other states the
possibility of having to ration
life-saving care new video from inside
valleywise medical center in phoenix
where covid patients now fill
all but one floor how crowded is it
inside there
100 understand capacity dr frank
lovecchio says it's not uncommon for
patients to wait a day
for a bed if somebody asked me how's my
day going i say
it's all coveted all the time what's it
like for the coco patients that you see
in there
the great majority of patients that come
in now are sicker
during the first wave people came in
with mild to moderate symptoms but now
you know patients are so savvy they know
to talk to their doctor maybe read on
the internet
and they come in when they're sicker the
state's second wave started after
thanksgiving when hospitals began
filling up health officials here
estimate more than 10 percent
of the state's population is now
infected with covid19
if the situation worsens so-called
triage officers would be asked to make
possible
life-or-death determinations it does
mean that we might have to make
very difficult decisions about what type
of care would be available for an
individual patient
we hope we do not get there we're asking
you we're imploring you today
to help us avoid that while vaccines are
offering hope like in much of the
country arizona initially had some
problems
it's just really hard to see people
struggling to breathe and it's scary
nurse nicole kohler has been working
nonstop in covit critical care at banner
desert hospital in phoenix
so when the vaccine became available she
was quick to apply
but she was told a computer glitch meant
she would have to wait
six weeks i started crying because i was
like six weeks i work in covid units
every single day and how can it take
this long
kohler continued working 12-hour shifts
at the hospital
she finally got her vaccine on december
26th
but it was too late the nurse who also
has asthma
was diagnosed with covid a week later i
started breaking out in cold sweats and
was really nauseous and had the body
aches in my mind i'm like
okay am i gonna end up like my patients
if i got my vaccine two weeks before
i might have had you know at least a
better shot with immunity
it's been kind of heartbreaking for me
because i got pretty sick
kohler had to stay home from her job for
two weeks at a time when every medical
professional
is badly needed she is feeling better
now and will be back at work next week
meanwhile doctors are now calling for a
statewide
mass mandate carter thank you very much